una pelea que lleva años es el agua
vital para millones de personas
el recurso aquí en disputa y más
específicamente qué cantidad de las
aguas del río nilo se pueden almacenar y
apartar en etiopía en lugar de fluir
hacia egipto y sudán en 2011 etiopía
inició la construcción de la represa con
una capacidad de 74 mil millones de
metros cúbicos de agua el proyecto de
infraestructura de 5 mil millones de
dólares es un motivo de orgullo para el
país africano una vez terminada será la
represa hidroeléctrica más poderosa de
áfrica pero el embalse se conecta con el
nilo azul el principal afluente del río
nilo que proporciona casi toda el agua
de la que dependen egipto y sudán en
marzo el presidente egipcio dijo que su
país está unido sobre la necesidad de
establecer límites
tuvimos la misma posición de rechazar
los intentos de etiopía de imponer como
un hecho cumplido lo del nilo azul a
través de medidas unilaterales que no
tienen en cuenta los derechos de los dos
países aguas abajo la semana pasada el
mandatario advirtió sobre una
inestabilidad que nadie puede imaginar
si se saca una sola gota de agua de
egipto una amenaza de conflicto no está
descartada y es una idea que permaneció
en el trasfondo de la última ronda de
conversaciones mientras los ministros
negociaban sobre la velocidad a la que
se llenará el embalse como se repondrá
cada año y exactamente cuánta agua se
liberaría si hubiera una sequía
importante
egipto quiere un acuerdo legalmente
vinculante que establezca los términos
futuros algo con lo que etiopía no está
totalmente de acuerdo también se negocia
quien debería supervisar las futuras
disputas sudán y egipto quieren
mediadores como la unión europea eeuu y
la onu junto con la unión africana para
ayudar a resolver cualquier desacuerdo
pero etiopía dice que cree en resolver
los problemas africanos con las naciones
del continente